Showtime's horror drama Penny Dreadful dropped
its biggest twist during its season three
finale, "The Blessed Dark": the series was
over. While the show is still having its last
rites read, let's investigate the potentially
spoiler-filled mystery of why it had to end...
Declining viewership
The last season of Penny Dreadful was not
a ratings juggernaut, clocking in at number
six among Showtime’s ten original shows,
behind Billions and The Affair. Viewership
had dropped over 5% compared to the previous
year. While other shows had fewer viewers,
Penny Dreadful’s elaborate settings and
special effects made it far more expensive
to produce. A cult following just wasn't enough.
A little over half a million people watched
the series finale live.
Money
Like most TV cancellations, money was likely
a large factor in Showtime's decision to give
Penny Dreadful the axe. It happened to plenty
of other fan favorite shows over the years;
Firefly, Hannibal, Constantine, and Dollhouse
among them. Despite featuring public domain
characters like Dracula, Dr. Jekyll, Frankenstein’s
monster, and Dorian Gray, the price of bringing
this many monsters to the screen couldn’t
have been cheap.
Vanessa Ives’ departure
Despite all the interesting characters she's
met over the past three years, Penny Dreadful
is a tale about Vanessa Ives. The series ended
with her finally finding peace, and while
we’ll never see her tangle with The Creature
or Dorian Grey again, this sudden ending is
how it was planned.
"I see...our lord."
Showtime CEO David Nevin said to Entertainment
Weekly,
"I always knew it wasn't going to be a really
long-running show—John Logan made that clear
coming in."
While there are plenty of tales you could
tell without her in this dark world, Ives
was the focal point of this show, and we couldn't
imagine it continuing without her. Remember
how The X-Files felt without Mulder? Gross.
More monsters
Without Vanessa Ives, Penny Dreadful is pretty
much just a bunch of 19th century ghouls.
If that’s your thing, you'll be seeing a
lot more of them soon. Universal Pictures
is launching its own set of films featuring
the most classic of movie monsters. The series
began with Dracula Untold in 2014. Meanwhile,
The Mummy reboot, starring Tom Cruise, is
scheduled for 2017. Don't be surprised if
TV executives try bringing Frank, Drac, and
the whole monster squad back to capitalize
on Hollywood digging them up from their graves.
It was foretold
There are various reasons why Penny Dreadful
was canceled, but we're gonna have to go with
show creator John Logan's explanation. Apparently,
he knew this was how the series would end
from the very beginning. But the cast found
out halfway through filming season two. In
Logan’s own words:
"Penny Dreadful was always intended to go
for three years exactly. So, I think we've
told our story well, and thank you for all
your support and hanging in there with us."
All good things come to an end. Sorry, Game
of Thrones fans. You too will know this sting.
We're sure you'll see most of these characters
in other forms soon enough, though.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know what you’ll miss the most about
Penny Dreadful...